[موسيقى]
فاز حزب العداله والتنميه المغربي
ب15 نائبا في البرلمان في الانتخابات
التشريعيه التي جرت يوم امس في المغرب ما
يجعله في المرتبه الاولى ويخول تشكيل
الحكومه لكنه مضطر للبحث عن تحالفات هذا
في حين حل في المرتبه الثانيه حزب الاصاله
والمعاصره بحصوله على
102 من المقاعد فيما حل ثالثا حزب
الاستقلال هذا وقد بلغت نسبه المشاركه في
هذه الانتخابات
43 في من المسجلين
فظن فوز جديد لحزب العداله والتنميه في
ثاني انتخابات تشريعيه تنظمها المملكه بعد
الحراك الشعبي لعام 2011 والتعديل
الدستوري الذي تلاه نحن اختيارتنا كما اكد
على ذلك دائما الاخ الامين العام هي تسير
في اتجاه الوفاء لحلفائه الذين وفوا لنا
كاصل وبعد ذلك ننظف الاحتمالات
الاخرى مع اخذ بع الاعتبار بطبيعه الحال
ان هناك خطوط حمراء تم التعبير عليها وهي
واضحه فيما يتعلق
بالتحالف الحزب ذو المرجعيه الاس ينتظر ان
يقود اذا الحكومه المغربيه خمس سنوات اخرى
لكنه يحتاج الى حلفاء لتامين اغلبيه
برلمانيه تمكنه من ذلك فما هي الخيارات
المطروحه امامه الخيار الاول وهو التحالف
مع حزب الاساره
والمعاصره والذين يقولون بان هذا غير ممكن
يجب ان نؤكد هنا ان الخط الاحمر قيل في
السياق ما قبل الانتخابات وفي السياسه ليس
هناك ثوابت
الان نتكلم عن تحالفات ما بعد
الانتخابات اما الخيار الثاني امام
العداله والتنميه فهو اقناع حلفاء الامس
بالبقاء الى جانبه وعلى راسهم حزب
الاستقلال لان حزب الاصاله والمعاصره
مازال مصرا على ما يسميه مشروعه من اجل
مجتمع حداثي ما يجعل اي تحالف مع حزب
العداله والتنميه امرا غير وارد حزب
الاصاله والمعاصره لازال على مبداه القار
هو لا تحالف مع الاله والتنميه وينص
الدستور المغربي على ان الملك يعين رئيس
الحكومه من الحزب الذي فاز باكبر عدد من
مقاعد مجلس النواب لكن هذا الدستور لم
يتطرق لفرض عدم تمكن الحزب الفائز من
تكوين تحالف برلماني يضمن له تشكيل
الحكومه ما قد يفتح الباب حسب خبراء
دستوريين على احتمال العوده مجددا الى
صناديق الاقتراع عبد المنعم العمراني
الجزيره
الرباط ومعنا هنا في استديو التغطيه في
الرباط محمد الهيني الناشط السياسي
والحقوقي مرحبا بك سيد محمد مرح شكرا كيف
يمكننا قراءه نتائج الانتخابات مع محافظه
حزب العداله والتنميه على المركز الاول
تراجع اليسار بشكل كبير
وتقدم الاصاله والمعاصره ربما على حساب
اليسار هذه المره بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
بدايه نهنئ وطن على تنظيم الانتخابات اللي
مرت بواحد الجو جيد وشفاف هذه ثاني
انتخابات بعد دستور 2011 اللي ك كرس
الاختيار الديمقراطي كمرتكز لا محيده عنه
في اطار العمليه
الديمقراطيه كتقييم لنتائج الانتخابات
يمكن القول ان تربع او تصدر حزب العداله
والتنميه لنتائج الانتخابات في المغرب
نتيجه شخصيا اعتبرها غير متوقعه على
اعتبار ان الحزب بشر اصلاح بشر مجموعه من
الكوارث اجتماعيه حصيلته مدمره في المجال
الاجتماعي عدم تشغيل العاطلين عدم عدم
توظيف الاساتذه المتدربين فصل التكوين عن
التوظيف الهجوم على الاطر المعطله الهجوم
على اساتذه التعليم اصلاحات او اصلاحات
تقاعد مدمره اصلاحات تخريبيه يعني يمكن
القول ان المجال اكبر من نسبه مديونيه
للاصلاحات الاجتماعيه والاقتصاديه كانت
مكلفه جدا لكن هذه الصوره هذه الصوره التي
ترسمها وتقول ان نتائج لم تكن
متوق لم يشهدها المواطن المغربي ولذلك فقد
اعطاه النسبه السابقه واضاف عليها اكثر من
25 نائبا هذا يعني بان من انتخبه لا يرى
ما تراه من امور مدمره كما تقول هذا شيء
غريب فعلا لاحظنا نسبه المشاركه حددها
وزير الداخليه في 43% ولكن يجب اخذ ايضا
بالاعتبار هناك مجموعه من المغاربه
مقاطعين العمليه الانتخابيه واغلبيه فيهم
مثقفه حزب العداله والتنميه حصل على هذ
النتائج لانه بنى خطابه السياسي بنى مجده
السياسي على خطاب المظلوميه ودائما يقول
ان ان المحيط الملكي هو من يحكم فجئا
مؤخرا بان رئيس الحكومه يقول بان الملك هو
رئيس الحكومه في خرق فاضح للدستور هذه
الحكومه شوهت الدستور لكن هو الان هو الان
هو الان في الحكم وعاده المعروف ان من من
هو في الحكم يخسر في الانتخابات هذه
التجربه هذه التجربه كانت مختلفه هو في
الحكم وتقدم في الانتخابات اكثر من السابق
كيف تفهم هذه النتيجه باختصار عندي معطيات
موضوعيه اولا الحزب بنى هويته على
الايديولوجيه المغاربه بعض المغاربه
يعتقدون انه بتصويته على حزب العداله
والتنميه يصوتون على الدين الاسلامي
ويعتقدون ان ان حزب عداله والتنميه سيحمي
الاسلام في حين ان حزب ان حزب عداله
والتنميه يقول يتبرر اصلا من مرجعيته
القانونيه او استغلوا استغلوا في حملتهم
الدينيه استغل
في ال قراءه في قراءه هذه النتائج اي يعني
واضح بانه حزب العداله والتنميه اخذ في
المدن بينما الاحزاب الاخرى تحديدا حزب
الاصاله والمعاصره كان في الارياف و
البداوي لكن السؤال المطروح لماذا تراجع
اليسار وتقدم عليه حزب الاصاله والمعاصره
اريد ان افهم هذه النقطه بالتحديد اليسار
لا يعتمد خطاب اسلامي يعتبر خطاب الدوله
المدنيه الدوله الحديثه
الاسلاميون يعتمدون خطاب خطاب الدين
بالشكل
تطرفين الثانيه لازم الاشاره اليها ان
الانتخابات ايضا من المهم الاشاره الى
انها حزب حزب الاصاله والمعاصره شكل تطورا
تاريخيا وكبيرا جدا بحيث المقاعد اكثر من
120% نسبه المقاعد وهذا ما يعكس ان هناك
الان ثنائيه قطبيه ان الاصاله والمعاصره
تصدر المشهد السياسي بالاضافه لحزب
العداله والتنميه ويشكل منافس حقيقي لانه
يمثل التيار المدني التيار الحدثي في
مواجهه التيار الرجعي للعداله والتنميه
اشكرك جزيلا محمد الهيني الناشط السياسي
والحقوق شكرا
لكم مشاهدينا اعاد نجاح المغرب في عبور
محطه الانتخابات التشريعيه اعاد النقاش
مجددا حول ما بات يسمى
بالاستثناء المغربي ليس فقط في استمرار
الالتزام باجراء انتخابات تتوافر فيها
مستويات لافته عربيا من حيث النزاهه
والشفافيه بل ايضا في النموذج الذي بات
يقدمه المغرب في شكل العلاقه بين
الاسلاميه وانظمه الحكم في العالم
العربي اختبار جديد للنظام الملكي في
المغرب هكذا وصف متابعون الانتخابات
البرلمانيه التي نظمت للمره الثانيه بعد
خمسه اعوام من حراك سياسي وشعبي شهدته
البلاد عام 2011 افضى الى تعديل دستوري
استفتي الشعب عليه تلاه انتخابات تشريعيه
جاءت بحكومه ائتلافيه يقودها حزب العداله
والتنميه دستور جديد وانتخابات ضمن حزمه
اصلاحات اخرى اجراها العاهل المغربي بعد
خروج احتجاجات نظمتها حركه العش من فبراير
مطالبه بتغيير ديمقراطي في المملكه خمس
سنوات اثبت فيها المغرب انه ماض في طريق
التداول السلمي للسلطه في مقابل صوره اخرى
بدول المنطقه التي عصفت ف رياح التغيير
والثوره عام 2011 لكنها تعيش اليوم ظروفا
مغايره تماما لما كانت شعوبها تصبو
اليه قد تكون تونس المثال الاقرب نسبيا
الى الحاله المغربيه من حيث سلميه المشهد
فيها بالرغم من ان كثيرين يعتبرون ان ثوره
الياسمين وان نجحت
بالاطاحة
وفي مصر التي استلهمت حركه العش من فبراير
المغربيه حراكها الشعبيه منها عام
2011 مشهد مغاير فالثور التي نجحت في
ازاحه مبارك ونظامه انتجت ثوره مضاده
اطاحت بالرئيس المنتخب واعادت العسكر الى
حكم البلاد ومن جديد عاد الحديث عن تقييد
الحقوق والحريات وتعالت الانتقادات في
الداخل
والخارج اما ليبيا التي انطلقت فيها هي
الاخرى شراره الثوره في فبراير عام 2000
ضد حكم معمر القذافي فقد تحول المشهد فيها
الى نزاع دموي وحرب اهليه وتمزقت البلاد
بين حكومات متعدده وبرلمان منقسم ومستقبل
مجهول هو المجهول ذاته الذي تواجهه سوريا
بلد بدا فيها الحراك الشعبي سلميا عام
2011 قبل ان يقم مع نظام الاسد ليتحول
لاحقا الى نزاع دموي مسلح تجاوز الداخل
الى صراع تشارك فيه قوى اقليميه
ودوليه اليمن السعيد الذي خرج ابناؤه ايضا
طلبا للحريه سقط في براثن الفرقه والنزاع
فبعد ازاحه علي عبد الله صالح فشلت
المرحله الانتقاليه وانتهى الامر بانقضاء
الحوثيين على الحكم ودخلت البلاد في اتون
حرب من غير المعلوم متى وكيف
ستنتهي معظم هذه الدول العربيه التي عصفت
فيها رياح التغيير تعيش واقعا ماساويه
وتنتظر مستقبلا مجهولا لا تبدو فيه اي
افاق لعمليه انتقال سياسي ديمقراطي للسلطه
وبصرف النظر عن الظروف الاقليميه والدوليه
التي تحيط بتلك الدول التي شهدت الحراكه
الطامحه للتغيير فان تجربه المغرب التي
بدات بشكل مشابه تقف اليوم وقد كرست
نموذجا للتداول السلمي
للسلطه و معنا هنا في استديو التغطيه في
المغرب عبد العالي حامد الدين عضو الامانه
العامه لح حزب العداله والتنميه مرحبا بك
سيد حامد الدين كحزب عداله وتنميه كيف
فهمتم نتائج هذه الانتخابات وكيف قيمت
موها هذه
نتائج جيده بالنسبه لحزب العداله والتنميه
اثبتت صوابه الكثير من اختياراته اثبتت
بان المغاربه يفهمون خطابه جيدا اثبتت
بانه حزب وطني غيور على استقرار المغرب
قدم الكثير من الاصلاحات المهمه التي
انقذت الاقتصاد الوطني بعدما كان نسبه
العجز في المغرب 7.9 اصبحنا الان 4. اثين
قامت بالكثير من الاصلاحات على المستوى
الاجتماعي الكثير من الاصلاحات على
المستوى الاقتصادي والاهم في ذلك انها
ضمنت للمغرب وساهمت في تكريس الاستقرار في
بلادنا الشيء الذي يجعلنا اليوم نمثل
بالفعل استثناء في المنطقه المغربيه وهذه
الانتخابات كذبت جميع الاطروحات التي كانت
تتحدث عن اغلاق القوس الديمقراطي الذي
انطلق بعد بعد الربيع العربي اليوم المغرب
اثبت بانه ماض في اختياراته الديمقراطيه
لكنه اثبت ايضا انه يريد مواصله الاصلاح
مع حكومه الاستاذ عبد الا ما رايكم بالقول
بان حزب العداله والتنميه استخدم خطاب
المظلوميه واستغل الخطاب الديني في
استقطاب الناخبين على العكس من ذلك
الوقائع تثبت بان من استغل الخطاب الديني
هو الذي استغل المساجد من اجل تحريض الناس
لعدم التصويت على حزب العداله والتنميه
ولم يثبت
بعكس حزب العداله والتنميه بنى خطابه
السياسي على حصيلته الانتخابيه لكنه بناه
ايضا على منهجه في الاصلاح المبني على
التراكم المبني على التعاون مع المؤسسات
المبني على الصدق المبني على قول الحقيقه
للمواطنين المبني على مواجهه التحكم
والتهديدات التي كانت تستهدف التجربه
الديمقراطيه المغربيه الان يعني كما هو
منصوص عليه في الدستور حزب العداله
والتنميه يفترض ل احد من حزب العداله
والتنميه ان يكلف بتشكيل
الحكومه ما هي صوره التحالفات الاوليه
التي يفكر فيها حزب العداله والتنميه كما
تفضلتم وحسب مقتضيات الدستور المغربي من
المنتظر ان يعين الملك رئيس الحكومه من
حزب العداله والتنميه بعد ذلك بدون شك فان
رئيس الحكومه سوف يباشر مسلسلا من
المفاوضات مع احزاب سياسيه انطلاقا من
رؤيته الخاصه لكن بالنسبه في حزب العداله
والتنميه فان التوجه العام هو نحن نمد
يدنا لجميع الاحزاب السياسيه من اجل
التعاون باستثناء حزب الاصاله والمعاصره
الذي لا نتعامل معه كحزب سياسي لا نرفضه
كحزب سياسي قائم ولكن نرفض اسلوبه في
العمل السياسي نرفض اسلوب الابتزاز اسلوب
تهديد المواطنين اسلوب تهديد الاعيان
اسلوب استخدام المال من اجل شراء الكثير
من المواقع الالكترونيه والصحافه الورقيه
وفبركه الملفات هذا الحزب حصل على 100
ومقعدين وقد تقدم على معظم الاحزاب او على
كل الاحزاب اليساريه وحل في المرتبه
الثانيه الا يعني ذلك بانه بدا يبني فعلا
ارضيه حقيقيه تنافس وتجعل هناك قطبيه
ثنائيه في المغرب يمكن ان اؤكد لك بان هذا
الرقم بدون معنى سياسي لانه جميع
المنتخبين اغلب هؤلاء المنتخبين ليس لهم
عمق فكري او ايديولوجي او سياسي وانما
منتخبون من طرف الاعيان الذين تم
استقطابهم من احزاب اخرى بواسطه اسلوب
الابتزاز والتهديد والترغيب
وبواسطه اسلوب لا علاقه له بالديمقراطيه
الحقيقيه ولذلك فاننا مطمئنون بان
اختيارات المغاربه اليوم هي مع حزب
العداله والتنميه بدرجه اساسيه هي مع
القوى السياسيه المستقله هي مع الاحزاب
الوطنيه الديمقراطيه لكن بالفعل تضررت
الكثير من الاحزاب التي سكتت عن اسلوب
الاصاله والم صره في مباشره التحكم التي
هادنت التحكم تجني اليوم بالفعل هذا يصعد
عليكم تشكيل
الحكومه لا اعتقد تشكيل الحكومه اعتقد
بانه سيمر بسلاسه على اعتبار انه هناك
مقاعد مريحه تضمن
للاحزاب الموجوده اليوم في البرلمان ان
تشكل حكومه اغلبيه مريحه عبد العالي حمد
الدين عضو الامان لحزب العداله والتنميه
اشكرك
جزيلا الى هنا مشاهدينا ناتي الى ختام هذه
النافذه تغطيه الانتخابات البرلمانيه
المغربيه اشكر متابعتكم والى اللقاء باذن
الله عوده الان الى الدوحه مع خديجه
ومحمود